we love you Hilary Duff and we can't
wait to watch the 20/20 reboot of Lizzie
McGuire we're curious to find out what
you and Gordo have been up to since your
2003 graduation trip to Rome but your
reboot has got us thinking about all the
fantastic TV remakes we encountered this
decade and there was like a lot of them
tons of amazing TV series have
triumphantly returned to the small
screen this decade and some might even
say they're better than the originals
while a few of these remakes totally
flopped others gave reboots of very good
names keep watching to find out which
frozen actors breakthrough TV series was
finally rebooted in the summer of 2019
chilling Adventures of Sabrina back in
1996 Sabrina the Teenage Witch hit the
small screen and it had viewers
everywhere wishing they had powers -
Sabrina Spellman was played by Melissa
Joan Hart and her kooky aunts hilda and
Zelda were portrayed by Caroline Raya
and Beth Broderick despite centering
around witches this show was a
light-hearted and kid friendly TV series
that the entire family could enjoy but
that isn't exactly the case for its 2008
teen remake chilling Adventures of
Sabrina is a lot darker and creepier
than the TV show it's based on and
that's what makes it so amazing the show
has kept most of its main characters
like Sabrina Hilda Zelda Salem and
Harvey however dozens of new characters
have been added to the cast
you can catch chilling Adventures of
Sabrina and Netflix the series has been
renewed for a fourth season however it's
release day is still under wraps
Kiernan Shipka stars as the ultra
powerful Sabrina Spellman and Ross Lynch
co-stars as Sabrina's one true love
Harvey kinkle Girl Meets World
if there's one TV series that totally
ruled the 90s
it's Boy Meets World what made this show
so special is that it literally grew up
with its audience the series followed
Corey his girlfriend Topanga and his
best friend Sean as they tried to make
sense of the world it was a
coming-of-age series that was both
hilarious and heartwarming Boy Meets
World aired from 1993 to 2000
in 2013 the Disney Channel would
announce that they were planning on
adding to the franchise the first season
of Girl Meets World aired in 2014 and it
would go on to have a total of three
seasons fans of the original series
couldn't help but watch the reboot after
all many of them now had kids of their
own
who were of an age with Cory and
topanga's children then savage and
danielle fishel reprised their roles as
Cory and Topanga and their children
Riley and Auggie Matthews were played by
Rowan Blanchard and August maturo
respectively were you a fan of this
series tell us in the comments charmed
did you grow up wishing you are a chosen
one well then you probably watched your
fair share of charmed episodes terms
first aired in 1998 and would go on to
have a total of eight seasons the series
initially followed sisters Piper Phoebe
and Cru Halliwell as they use their
powerful witchcraft to battle against
the forces of evil the show starred
Holly Marie Combs Alyssa Milano and chin
and Doherty
sadly conflicts between the leading
ladies would later switch up the dynamic
of the show Charmed was such a hit in
the late 90s producers didn't think
twice when it came to creating a reboot
while the reboot followed a very similar
path as the original there were some
notable differences between the two
Melanie Diaz and Sarah Jaffrey played
Mel and Maggie Vera and Madeleine man
talk portrayed Melon Maggie's
half-sister niece Yvonne
despite the CW having high hopes for the
reboot charmed didn't receive the best
ratings and it looks like the show will
come to an end after just two seasons
but fans of the reboot are still hoping
for a season 3 announcement are you
afraid of the dark if you're a
millennial chances are you often slept
with your parents after watching are you
afraid of the dark
while this TV series wasn't exactly
terrifying it was pretty spooky for
young children every episode would start
and end with a group of kids telling
scary stories around a campfire and some
of these stories have stuck with us
until this very day in October 2009 teen
a reboot of the popular show finally hit
the small screen just in time for
Halloween while the series is still
airing its first season fans of the show
have already stated that the reboot is
just as terrifying as the original the
three-part self-contained limited series
is a must watch
on a sidenote did you know that Ryan
Gosling appeared on an episode of are
you afraid of the dark in 1995 that's
right it was one of his first-ever roles
which episode of this timeless series
has stuck with you until this very day
we have to admit we're still a little
traumatized by the tale of the dollmaker
High School Musical the musical de
series if you're a Disney plus member
you're probably a fan of the high school
musical reboot High School Musical the
musical the series this mini series has
a total of 10 episodes which follows
this student of East High School as they
attempt to put on a play of the original
High School Musical movie problem is
these students aren't all in this
together like the original cast fans of
the 2006 Disney Channel original movie
couldn't believe their eyes and ears
when news of the reboot pulls through
the internet the first episode of the
remake aired on Disney Plus in November
of 2019 and it's all set to continue
into the new year High School Musical
the series stars olivia rodriguez nene
joshua basset as ricky and sophia wiley
as Gina there are some notable
differences between both versions like
the fact that the students at East High
aren't very keen on sticking to the
status quo if you like hearing about
shows from your childhood hit that
subscribe button to get your daily dose
of nostalgia once you join the things
family click that Bell to turn on
notifications this way we can let you
know as soon as we post a new video but
if you're tuning in on your tablet or
phone make sure to switch on
notifications in your YouTube settings
fuller house if you were a fan of the
sitcom full house you were definitely
excited when it was announced that the
beloved series was making a comeback in
2016 the remake would serve as a
continuation of the series and it was
super well received by fans full house
aired from 1987 to 1995 throughout the
show's eight seasons we got acquainted
with the Tanner family mary-kate and
Ashley Olsen would portray little
Michelle Tanner and actors John Stamos
and Bob Saget would serve as the show's
leading men full house will go down in
history as one of the most cherished
family sitcoms of all
I'm so in fans of the show found out
that fuller house was in the works they
were thrilled fuller house is currently
airing its fifth and final season the
reboot aired on Netflix making it easy
for fans to binge watch the series just
like full house fuller house tells the
story of a single parent who is raising
three children with the help of their
hilarious family members Riverdale the
Archie comics are timeless and plenty of
Millennials grew up reading them so when
the CW announced that they would be
making a live-action remake of the 1999
animated series Archie's weird mysteries
fans that the franchise could hardly
contain their excitement
the animated series aired for one single
season in 1999 but while Riverdale would
serve as a live-action reboot fans would
soon realize that it was nothing like
the comics Riverdale first aired in 2017
and it's cast is ripe with talent
KJ app' Lily Reinhardt Camilla Mendez
and Cole Sprouse played Archie Betty
Veronica and Jughead respectively while
the show received amazing reviews during
its first and second seasons the same
can't be said about its third and fourth
prompting fans to believe that the CW
won't be renewing Riverdale for a fifth
season are you a fan of this live-action
remake tell us in the comments carmen
sandiego netflix is at it again and this
time they're not messing around when it
comes to reboots back in the late 90s
master thief carmen sandiego made waves
as one of the most famous cartoon
characters of all time and netflix has
picked up where carmen left off carmen
sandiego is the animated remake of where
on earth is Carmen Sandiego this
franchise first started as an
educational game designed to help
children master the globe but its
popularity skyrocketed and in 1994
carmen was given her very own animated
TV show the Netflix original series
first aired in 2019 and is currently on
its second season Carmen Sandiego is
voiced by Jane the Virgin's Gina
Rodriguez and player is played by
stranger things spin wolfhard
this exciting cast helps bring these
nostalgic characters to life on the
small screen here's a fun fact for you
the original character chief was played
by Rodger Bumpass who is famous for
voicing Squidward from SpongeBob
SquarePants
Star Trek discovery the Star Trek
franchise is timeless and over the last
five decades a handful of TV series have
been created in its honor Star Trek the
original series first aired from 1966 to
1969 and in 2001 the reboot titled Star
Trek Enterprise followed suit if you're
a huge Star Trek fan you were probably
super stoked to find out that the series
would be getting reboot in 2017 this
news was made all the more exciting when
it's cast of amazing actors was made
public Star Trek Discovery's 3rd season
is all set to air in January of 2020
Veronica Mars Kristen Bell is one of the
most successful actors in the world in
2004 she was cast as Veronica Mars which
would serve as her breakthrough role
fans of the show were devastated when
the series wrapped up after three short
seasons so it comes as no surprise that
Veronica Mars received a reboot in 2019
in 2007 Kristen would voiced Gossip Girl
on the hit TV series by the same name
and funny enough this dramatic series
will also receive a reboot in 2020 while
season four of Veronica Mars received
good reviews it's unclear whether or not
the show will be renewed for a fifth
season
Kristen Bell is one busy lady if she
voices on in the frozen franchise and
also stars on Netflix is
good place Veronica Mars centered around
a high school student named Veronica who
served as a young private eye in the
crime infested town of Neptune and
that's a wrap on the ten TV shows from
your childhood that were brought back
this decade before you go tell us what
your top three favorite reboots are in
the comments section below thank you for
watching the things don't forget to give
this video a big thumbs up we'll catch
you later
[Music]
you